no
how well cristian casseres greets you with
his brief information from news now in
spanish a power outage was reported at the
international port i stayed on
friday morning the airport
reported that this blackout affected
different sectors of terminal 1 in
addition to areas  of the parking lot
airport officials say that if you
have to travel through the area try to
plan your trip in advance and I tell you
that the las vegas wailers are
asking for proof of vaccination for
all people over 12 years old when
attending the game at home yes  you cannot
submit the vaccination card to the
application now there will be a tent where you
can receive help located in zone b
of the adiyiah stadium this will be
from saturday 9 in the morning until 5 in
the afternoon and also on sunday 9 in the
morning  until 2 in the afternoon
the rich group together with other
organizations will be offering
free services for mental health
and medical care for residents  s this
weekend there you can get
the flu vaccine el cob and
hiv tests among others this event
will be on saturday at the club vigués
community center at 9 in the morning
visit news now dot com for more
information and we start the weekend  during the
week with clouds and rain, Friday
will be a cloudy day with temperatures
of 76 degrees, a partially cloudy sky awaits us
with temperatures
of 70 degrees and lows of 50 and do not put
away your umbrella because on Monday there is
a slight chance of rain I am
cristian cásseres with his but
informative of news I read in Spanish good
day